Andrew Tate has taken the Internet by
storm over the last 12 months with his
misogynistic viewpoints resonating with
young men it has allowed him to reach
never-before-seen amounts of Fame in
this video we'll be going over the
effect Andrew Tate has had on young men
specifically myself over the last year
I'm gonna give my thoughts on some of
his more controversial takes if you're
some fat dude and you just had a heart
attack and I don't really know you
you're gonna die the arrest The Matrix
has attacked me and I went from a nice
happy kid to well you'll see Haram like
most of you guys I never actually heard
of Andrew Tate before April 2022 when he
started his massive Tick Tock run and
this is actually the first text that I
ever got introducing me to Tate I never
heard of him before this text right here
I believe this was April 20th 2022
pretty crazy at first like everyone else
of course I thought Andrew Tate was
crazy I mean saying stuff like tap
Waters for brokeys women can't park I
wouldn't give CPR to my boy unless it's
a hot girl I mean it was nuts but I did
see the genius in what he was doing so
as you guys know now now he was saying
super controversial stuff at first to
grab everyone's attention and make it so
that any time his video popped up on
your feed in the future you'd want to
sit there and watch the whole thing to
see what he had to say and then slowly
as he gathered more people's attention
he transitioned his message from the
crazy stuff to more logical things so
that people would start to resonate with
him more and he would actually gain you
know some more loyal followers right
when hearing about Tate like I said this
was about April 2022 this was just after
um I was starting the exit of a previous
business that I was in late 2021 to
early 2022 it was my freshman year of
college and I was actually able to find
lots of success in business I started a
company which we generated five million
dollars in crypto related Ventures so
how does it go from tick tock to two and
a half million dollars that's insane
only 18 years old you know dropping out
of college having brought in this much I
basically thought I was the man a lot of
this was an nfts and it's funny I
remember after making my first large sum
of cash I was in New York with family
when we sold out one of our first drops
and I just hit six figures and I
remember right after it happened I
thought when I get back to school I'm
gonna have so many girls I'm gonna be
the man and funny enough it was kind of
the opposite you know that first month
of school when I was still more of a
regular guy I was getting way more girls
compared to after I made this money and
I think that I thought that you know
having money would get me so many girls
it's because that's what like the not
just the media but everyone says so much
like oh I just need money to get girls
but honestly it was like a reality check
like making money is such a small part
of it all I'll get into that more later
in the video but you guys know what Tate
says about crypto kids so I'm waiting
for the next pump I was like bro the
problem with you is you've now been
ruined for life because you're 22 you
made easy money and you think that you
don't have to ever do serious work I was
like one of those guys just a little bit
less geeky you know I didn't just catch
a random crypto pump and make tens of
millions of dollars I was actually
running a company so I had to put some
more brain into it so like I said still
April 2022 at the time his video started
uh popping up I was still talking to
this girl down in Miami this was
probably the most serious that I've ever
talked to a girl
um we were really close to dating
however I messed it up with her in so
many different ways some of the things I
did was we spent way too much time
together right off the bat I mean like
right off the bat it was like four hour
dinners just talking non-stop I seemed
too desperate to hang out with her so I
would ask like multiple times if she
said no I would be like oh come on come
on I didn't leave any sense of mystery
in what I do like I said I remember I
was in I was in web 3 at the time and I
remember this one time I was literally
explaining to her what nfts are you
could just take a screenshot bruh
I could go print a picture of the Mona
Lisa throw it on like you should never
have to explain to a girl what
non-fungible tokens are they don't need
to know that but um yeah I was lost with
girls we facetimed every night and worst
of all I cried in front of her once and
you might even be thinking right now
that some of those don't sound so crazy
you know showing emotion in front of
girls and crying is okay and texting
them all the time and not having any
sense of mystery that's all good things
and I can tell you that that's complete
[__] and I'll get into that later in
the video so the next few months after
we stopped talking I was still under the
mindset that it was her fault you know
she was inconsiderate she used me just
all these you know BS excuses then I
started to watch Tate some more not just
the tick tocks of him saying women can't
park I think the first long-form podcast
I watched of his was the Yo Mama's House
podcast Abdul yeah get the rock get the
rocks and this is where I really started
to actually like his message regardless
of if you like him or not you can't deny
he's an extremely intelligent and
engaging speaker from here I started
watching basically all of his podcast as
he was going on them and my world view
started to take a complete 180 in real
time one of his first points really
sticking with me being ultimate
self-accountability you need to as a man
adopt the mindset that absolutely
everything that happens to you is
completely not really your fault whether
it's good or bad and the Dynamics that
he teaches with women with those points
I was able to go back and look at all
those things that I did wrong in that
relationship before and recognize that
it was my fault and not actually the
girls and that's a good thing you know
being able to take self-accountability
for something like that that's the only
way that you're ever going to grow if
you only ever blame relationships and
stuff on other people how are you ever
expected to be a better partner in the
future so some of those things like I
said spending way too much time with her
and FaceTiming every night I was giving
way too much attention you know as a man
you need to have a value attached to
your attention and I'm a busy guy if you
give them attention all the time that
actually pushes them away and I know in
your head there's girls watching this
you think that you want the guy to give
you all the the attention but then why
aren't you texting the dudes that are
texting you all the time and when you're
in bed you're dreaming of the guy that's
ignoring you and then lastly like I said
keeping some mystery in what you do I
don't even have to explain this I mean
you should you should never be
explaining what nfts are to a girl
that's that's the last thing that you
should be talking about of all the
things in the English language that you
could be saying that is not this is not
what you should be saying on a date so
you know a lot of you guys have grown up
in the U.S as well as me and as you all
know depression is talked about greatly
um especially from a young age from the
time we're little we're taught about
people becoming depressed and sadly
killing themselves personally I've never
been depressed like others explain
depression to be however depression does
run in my family so my parents have
always been very worried about me if
Depression was ever going to come and
strike me this leads to arguably Tate's
most controversial point depression
isn't real specifically his analogy
where he said take two men one believes
in ghosts one doesn't there's a loud
noise in the night the one who believes
in ghosts wakes up and is paranoid is
afraid the one who doesn't believe in
ghosts goes back to sleep it is the
belief in the ghost which punishes him
not the ghost itself if you do not
believe in depression you can never be
depressed like I said though I've never
thought I was depressed meaning a
chemical imbalance in my brain but I
felt depressed before just like every
other human has the most depressed
probably that I've ever been was when I
was worth the most money that I've ever
been but it was while my entire company
was collapsing and I was having feuds
with the other Founders so when you
anyone would have looked at me and
thought that I was on top of the world
because I had this this big company um
and it looked like it was you know going
great behind the scenes it was actually
going to [__] and you know having my
whole brand attached to it and on my
passion in it for the last six months to
see it go to [__] I I was I was
genuinely uh you know I felt depressed
back to his point though ultimate
self-accountability is tied to this take
of depressed question not being real you
see what the mass media machine does is
it constantly victimizes people because
it knows it sets mental caps on what
they can achieve have you ever noticed
how if you're at the gym and you're
going to do 10 reps of a workout on that
10th rep it feels really hard and like
you couldn't get one more up yet if you
told yourself from the start you were
going to do 12 reps it would feel like
that on the 12th rep because that's
where you set the mental cap for
yourself it's all just a mental barrier
I know this might be more of a
controversial example but look at the
black community right now all the media
tells them is how they're oppressed they
live in a country where white men have
the advantage over them and that
anything bad that happens to them is
because of their race rather than
Shining Light on black people who went
from [__] circumstances to making it
like Andrew Tate and taking
self-accountability for everything that
happens to you now I want you to tell me
which agenda would the mass media
Machine push if they truly wanted
success for black people that they're
constantly victims and setting caps on
them or that you take self
accountability and show them that other
people like them have become successful
from worse circumstances
I don't know I want to tell a quick
story too regarding mental caps and
belief so right now I live in Florida
and about a month ago I had a trip to
Tulum Mexico so my sleep schedule at the
time was completely [__] um I was
going to sleep at like 5 a.m and I had a
9 A.M flight so I decided I was just
gonna stay up through the night drive to
the airport be tired and sleep on the
plane but my dumb ass thought Tulum was
on the west coast so that I had a five
hour flight and I was going back three
hours so I get to the airport I'm half
asleep the second I get on the plane I
pass out I wasn't awake for one second
while the plane was in the air I woke up
as we landed so I wake up I look at the
time it's two hours later I'm like damn
I got my five and a half hours of sleep
I am good I feel great so I go I go to
the resort meet up with all the guys and
it's not till nearly that night where I
realized that I was running on an hour
and a half of sleep the whole day now I
can guarantee you that if I knew Tulum
was eastern time and I knew I was only
getting an hour and a half that when I
Blended I would have still felt more
tired when I got to the resort I would
have been like oh I'm only running on an
hour and a half you know I should
probably go take a quick nap compared to
that Mental Cap being higher because I
thought I had that five hours that's
just a funny little story that I wanted
to share that covers how belief and
self-hypnosis really is so much more
powerful than you could possibly think
even right now it's 2 30 in the morning
as I'm filming this video I'm tired as I
finish the script I was thinking maybe I
should just push this off to tomorrow
when I'm more awake and the second that
thought came into my head I grabbed
myself by the balls get up grab your
ball and I said no we're gonna kill that
thought we're gonna dial in and we're
gonna get this done tonight because it's
all about the belief it's what I tell
myself all right so this is about two
months into listening to Tate and
although these mindsets might not seem
like a big deal they completely change
the way you look at the world so here
like I said two months until the same to
him I'm basically fully out of my old
company I had a big Feud with the other
Founders and it completely went to [__]
having no company but all this new
business and marketing experience that
I've learned I decided to go hard at
content creation so for those of you
guys that don't know my my expertise is
in short form marketing so Tick Tock
reels and shorts and I knew that with
this new content creation journey I
wanted to go viral as quickly as
possible so I knew that I had to find
something where I could combine these
short form marketing skills and a topic
that would get me to go as viral as
quickly as possible so I thought of the
mom reacts to Tate videos this was when
Andrew Tate was near his peak of
trendiness it was I think mid-july and
nobody else has done a mom reacts yet so
I basically knew that from this first
YouTube video I'm posting that it would
go extremely viral within a week it was
at over a hundred thousand views which
is which is unheard of for a new
YouTuber but it's what I do it's pretty
cool actually because these last seven
months since starting YouTube have been
the most rapid personal growth that I've
ever experienced so if you go back to
the First videos compared to now you can
clearly see how much more educated I
sound how much more articulate I am with
conveying my points and how much more
handsome I am of course and the thing is
I hope to look at my current self in six
months and think the same thing because
I'm constantly seeking for
self-improvement so starting YouTube I
like some of Tate's messages but I still
didn't know how to feel on some of his
takes with women you know men can cheat
women can't cheat a man could be head
over heels in love with you ready to
take a bullet for you and still cheat on
your ass and to be honest my honest
opinion is I understand both sides so
from Tate's perspective he's not talking
about the average dude he's talking
about the one percent man and how when
you're at that status your monogamy
becomes less important because your
other accolades make up for it and his
other point which I actually do agree
with that men and women cheating isn't
the same thing because men can detach
emotion from sex and do it just for
pleasure meanwhile sex for women is
mainly emotional which honestly makes
sense because as a woman if you're
having sex with a guy from a natural
person perspective you're taking the
risk of having to hold his baby for nine
months and then raise it rather as a guy
you're just spreading your seed I know
that's a simple answer but that's how it
is from the nature perspective but then
I also understand the other people's
point of view where you shouldn't be
cheating in a relationship behind your
partner's back and lying about it and
that as a man you should sacrifice those
desires to sleep with other women to be
in a loving relationship and especially
since casual sex is so meaningless so my
final take there is I don't want to
promote men cheating but I definitely do
think that it is different between men
and women I mean personally I'd much
rather have sex with a beautiful in
touch with their femininity pure woman
compared to meaningless sex with a girl
that I just I don't care about it's not
even in the same ballpark to me to be
honest as much as Tate and a lot of us
promote masculine Excellence female
Excellence is just as important Let me
Give an example if I was going on a few
dates with this girl who I know is a
virgin and let's say five dates in I
know that she's into me and she's down
to sleep with me however I just don't
feel the same way about her I'm not just
gonna sleep with her and then ghost her
just because I had the opportunity to
that is destroying that Purity and
feminine Excellence that she has inside
of her and putting a hard coat on her
for the Future these are the girls that
need to be protected not taken advantage
of and that's the thing the feminist
movement has convinced women that
sleeping around and having casual sex is
a good thing
but it's actually the opposite since sex
is so accessible to women the empowering
thing would be to tell women that only
the man who loves protects and provides
for you would be able to get access to
that very sacred part of your body not
just Joe schmoe plus the more women have
casual sex it makes them less likely to
be loyal in future relationships it
masculizes them and they're more likely
to be depressed in the future which is
sad but it's true I don't even want to
be sleeping around with a bunch of
random girls to be honest I was out the
other night with some girls
um in Florida and the one that I was
talking to was on antidepressants she
Vaped on birth control victim mindset
every single guy that she's previously
talked to it was his fault I mean that
[__] is just repulsive to me even though
I could have done stuff with her and I
know that she was down I didn't even
pursue it just because it's it's just
not interesting I want genuine feminine
energy around me because true feminine
energy is extremely powerful and it
comes binds with masculine energy very
well another thing is these women that
are always talking about equality and
double standards which is just
completely garbage I mean where's the
equality with me getting sent to war
because I'm a man if [__] hits the fan
in this country where if you accuse me
of rape I have hundreds of thousands of
dollars in legal fees and I have to to
protect my reputation for the rest of my
life just for it to come out that you
were lying and then you have no
repercussions where if we're on a
sinking ship your life is more valuable
than mine where if I get you pregnant I
have no say whether on to keep or kill
the baby but regardless you can leave me
sleep with another man and then charge
me two thousand dollars a month in
support I mean where's the equality
there it's [__] garbage but you know
I'm sure lasan and L3 L3 will find a way
to disagree with me this guy's been
breastfed till he was 14 and he's 15 now
and he's acting brand new you know what
I mean even though I feel like I'm a
pretty reasonable guy you know like I
analyze both sides and I try to find the
most logical takes the funny thing too
is women are obsessed with men like the
Tates but they just don't admit it
because they can't get a guy like that
this is why movies like 365 which [__]
bro that was horrible I don't know I
watched it with girls and it was
terrible or 50 Shades of Gray are so
popular because women naturally like to
be submissive and to be dominated they
like the Big G's the top men so what
they do when they can't get one is they
turn into men hating feminists
America don't call you toxically
masculine for getting those attributes
which they naturally want so honestly
with all of these new points instilled
into my head it has only changed my
experience with girls in a good way I'm
not thirsty I don't chase girls I would
never not like I ever did this force a
woman to do anything she doesn't want to
do whether it's sexually or come back to
the house come with me if she says no
that's perfectly fine remember you're
not [__] psycho it's all fine do
whatever you want I don't care I'm
myself I'm a gentleman I have a value
attached to my attention I do my own
thing and now that I've put this Focus
onto myself I'm actually getting about a
DM a day from different girls which is a
total first never had this before it's
kind of cool and I'm not saying that as
a brag because that's cringy brag but my
point being if you take your focus and
you put it into building yourself as a
man and upgrading your character
compared to if you put that focus into
going out and chasing girls the girls
will just naturally come to you it's
just a little bit of delayed
gratification and when you you delay the
gratification the quality of girls that
come is even better so I don't know why
everyone doesn't do this but hey more
for us I don't give a [__] so now with
these new mindsets and still to me here
I am about five months into listening to
Tate and this is where he reacted to our
content for the first time we have based
mom have you heard of the based mother
there's a guy who watches my videos with
his mother and she uh comments on them
and she's pretty basic I immediately
know if it's a hit piece or some
[__] video oh I know if it's a good
video just from what they look like I
gotta say here at this point in my life
he's already changed my mind in multiple
different ways so to have him reacting
to our videos it was it was honestly a
really really cool experience I remember
before I even started YouTube I knew a
guy that has met Tate and I thought that
was so cool so then to a few months
later having Tate react to my videos and
even get in contact with him pretty
awesome you know it's what happens when
when you constantly make the Right Moves
and try to level yourself up you know
make that new connection join this group
gets you close to where you want to be
off the women topic another big point of
Tates is you're the sum of The Five
People You spend the most time with the
five people you spend the most time with
that's what you're gonna end up like in
turn your brain is dictated by the
content that you consume so with that
knowledge why would we not only surround
ourselves with people who are trying to
be like or build ourselves with and
taking in useful content that benefits
us I mean this is something we all know
this isn't something Tate invented we've
all heard this before I remember even at
the start of my entrepreneurial Journey
all of my college friends still wanted
to keep going out drinking partying
doing that dumb [__] which I had fun for
a month of but it gets old pretty quick
because it doesn't actually take you
anywhere in life so to find those
connections that I wanted to start
business with and really level up I had
to do it online so honestly one of my my
best pieces of advice for you guys who
feel stuck and you're surrounded by
loser friends is to find a good Network
online join different groups maybe go to
different masterminds that's the best
way you can meet new people and then
stay in touch with them whether it's on
Discord calls texting whatever it is
it's important that you surround
yourself with positive people on the
same track as you whether it's in person
or digitally whatever you have to do and
it's sad honestly because once you get
on that trajectory you slowly start to
cut out and stop talking to those older
friends as much because they're just not
on the same same wavelength you know
once once you're on the entrepreneurial
self-improvement upgrade your character
wave it's tough to spend time with a lot
of people who just smoke weed and drink
all the time I mean it's impossible it's
like you feel like a bot to be quite
honest I can't do it then to the point
regarding the the content that you
consume you want to reprogram your mind
this is something that he talks about
and it's something I've learned on my
own so you know how in high school when
you would have to memorize random
nonsense like PEMDAS
[Music]
the capital of every single state all
this BS well I have been retraining my
brain in the same way but just with
useful knowledge so now when I'm walking
my dog or when I have my headphones in
or have something playing in the
background rather than it being some
garbage video that doesn't teach me
anything I switched it to educational
speakers I I turn on a podcast of people
that I aspire to be like when I do
listen to music I'm aware of the type of
music that I'm listening to so that that
garbage doesn't seep into my
subconscious so if you look up to Tate
for example and you want to have that
type of Lifestyle I would recommend
listening to a lot of his podcasts that
way it's almost like you're surrounding
yourself with him and you're adopting
that healthy mindset let's think about
this for a second imagine you only
listened to what the media told you to
do it's truly the Sheep's way study hard
go to college and get in debt for a
practically useless degree save your
money which they print more of every
single year and it becomes more useless
if you're depressed it's probably
because of a chemical imbalance so you
should take pills to help cure it get
every single jab that they tell you for
every single disease for regardless of
if it affects your health or not if you
got it during the scandemic gyms are
closed but liquor stores are open as
Necessities if you're a 10 year old who
can't focus in school and sit in a
classroom for eight hours a day you
should take focused medication because
there's something wrong with you as a
man it's not important to be strong and
you should be in touch with your
emotions kids can decide if they feel
like they want to be the other gender I
mean these are all common points that
the mass media machine makes could you
imagine where my life would be if I
blindly listen to these and don't even
get me started on what they say to woman
take antidepressants get on birth
control sleeping around is empowering
abortions are okay and they're good to
have it's better to rely on a job than a
man who loves and will die and provide
for you I mean it's completely
ridiculous it's a [__] joke and I'm
not even being crazy or or Out Of Reach
with a lot of these points I mean these
are common points that they're making
you know a lot of these times people
make you know political videos they'll
go after the other side's extremists I
mean those points that I'm making are
not even extreme that's just common of
what they tell you to do which is insane
enough of that [__]
um I know I said this before but this
take is my favorite of of Tates and
probably the most life-changing analyze
the chess board and make the best move
possible regardless of your position or
what you feel like it's very rare that
you look at the chessboard and go the
best thing I can do right now is jerk
off I mean this has completely changed
the way that I look at business and and
basically everything I mean I've been in
in points of business where it seems
like everything is completely falling
apart and I'm [__] but if you look at
life like a chessboard where you can
analyze every potential move you could
make everything you do is a potential
chest move so you see the business going
to [__] all you have to do is analyze
where stuff is going to [__] and then
what pieces you have to move what things
you have to do to fix those problems and
at the end of the day 99.9 of the time
there's a fix to those problems and
there's something you can do about it
it's just most people have the the
helpless mindset so they let it all
collapse in front of them even with any
business of mine if it's going well
that's that's how I look at it I think
okay conversion rates are are at four
percent how could we get this up to 4.5
it's like you analyze everything and
this is what makes business so fun
because it's the biggest chessboard in
the world and there's unlimited moves
you can make it's crazy it's crazy it's
crazy and then having a word of iron is
another one of Tate's best messages
where if you say something it becomes
true you gotta start saying [__] and
your word has to be iron and I don't
mean this in just like some kind of
manifestation way where I say I'm Gonna
Be A Millionaire where yeah that stuff
is great but I mean where if you say
something that you're gonna do it you
saying it it's already done so I say I'm
gonna do 100 push-ups because I say it
it's like I've already did it because
I'm going to do them now our generation
is absolutely horrible about sticking to
our word I mean realistically people's
word means genuinely nothing nowadays
whether it's Friends Business I I mean I
remember there's there's been times
where I'm visiting a friend at college
and we're like oh what are we going to
do tonight and my friend's like oh we'll
get some girls over bro and we'll just
hang out I'm like okay and then that
night he's just like oh yeah I like
texted a few and they didn't respond and
something even little like that but it's
like bro like you just say stuff to say
stuff and so many people do this where
they just say stuff without it having
any substance so when you start saying
stuff without it actually meaning
anything your word is meaningless
compared to if every single time you say
you're gonna do something and it happens
your word is like iron I know that might
sound like a dumb example but it's
little things like that that correlate
to every other aspect of your life you
say you're gonna do something you just
it has to get done if you're an editor
in business and you say You're Gonna
edit two videos a day for this person
it's done you said it you have to do it
and the thing is too I'm not even
perfect about this all the the time I
put too much onto my plate and then I'm
not able to get it all done and I say
I'm gonna have something to you tomorrow
and then it's it's there the day after I
mean we're all bad at this it's crazy
but you have to at least acknowledge it
and constantly work towards turning your
word into literal iron now with all
these these these great messages that
has spewed he is now arrested and he's
been in jail for about 90 days now for
sex trafficking The Matrix has attacked
me now what they initially hit him with
was you know sex trafficking broadly so
people thought he's like shipping girls
in the Ukraine in boxes but then when
you know everyone realized that was
complete [__] they hit him with the
Loverboy method now personally I think
that the Loverboy method is the most
[__] thing to ever accuse someone of
and there's a couple reasons why Point
number one if it was a woman
manipulating a man into doing something
there would be no outrage at all in fact
the media would celebrate it because
that's empowering for women number two
you guys are all about women's
Independence and stuff so you're gonna
sit here and tell me that women aren't
competent enough to make their own
decisions that a man could just make
them fall in love and then do stuff to
them I mean it's absolutely ridiculous
especially when Tate is paying the girls
out a salary like we're really supposed
to believe the human trafficking
allegations against Tate when the people
on Epstein's list are still out roaming
the streets and they're celebrities like
cardi B who have admitted to drugging
and robbing men and they're given
McDonald's Partnerships so then you're
gonna take those people who are actual
traffickers and should be in jail
compared to someone who made girls fall
in love with him to do work and then
still pay them and that guy should go to
jail what
whatever you know the true reason why
Tate's in jail I'll tell you because
this whole [__] would not work if
everybody listened to him the one thing
about Tate's message that makes the most
sense is the Matrix because none of it
would work if everyone had free Minds
you need these people convinced that
their time is worth ten dollars an hour
to flip Burgers you need these men
depressed so they can't stand up to the
[__] in front of their eyes having
to pay taxes while you're printing more
money at the same time you need this or
else none of it would work you see
YouTube won't even give me a plaque
which just shows that I'm doing
something right you think the platform
that gives fact Checkers on every post
about the scandemic or 7-Eleven not
giving me a plaque would mean I'm doing
something wrong nope opposite I'm
seeking truth when depression tubers
like lassan and L3 L3 are shoved down
your throat Life's too short to exercise
I'm just gonna be honest and I'm the one
that's suppressed that's how you know
I'm doing something right so overall I
went from crying over a girl and losing
my company to building a completely new
mindset to the point where I feel like a
different human being multiplying my
income become a stronger person Inspire
thousands created a massive Network and
its thanks to these messages that Tate
has instilled inside of me it's funny I
don't even think I've ever said this in
a video before but me and Tate were
actually supposed to do a podcast in
January in Dubai and one thing that I
can tell you for a fact is that podcast
is still gonna happen right when he is
out of prison unfortunately I had to
make this video a fake hit piece so that
the YouTube algorithm would actually
push it to people but if you made it
this far hopefully you took something
out of it and you realized why we
actually follow him not just because he
said women can't park make sure to
follow me on Instagram at sunnyfaz
follow my Twitter at the sunny fast let
me know what you thought of this kind of
video where I'm just talking to the
camera and giving my thoughts free top G
I love you all and I'll see you and
[Music]